we don't have any of those three today
okay uh and some would say with Trump
well you didn't have liability with
Trump but you had fear and respect say
what you want you better fear and
respect the guy you know hey you want to
do something Kasam Mani Boom the guy
that was a leader of six proxy
militaries he called himself the most
powerful General in the Middle East he
kills him and then it's like do
something and youan retaliates and bombs
a building in a military base that they
knew was empty just to say we ret iated
no he didn't why not cuz you know the
guy is crazy enough to do something to
you if you even touch him we need to
hurry up with this next election and get
somebody that's feared and respected or
else show is going to get even
worse and I think 2024 is going to be
really the year where America needs to
go back to being feared and respect